do you know something really disgusting
what's disgusting
this used to be like my couple goals
it's not anymore i realized i've grown
up
but a goal for me used to be like
sitting on the toilet seat and then like
if i'm and you need the toilet at the
same time and we only have one bathroom
you can just like weave through my leg
so both
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views you know i'm saying it's
all good right now charm aren't ya and
i've had some bad dates how do you think
you've done on the date i don't really
give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie about it
where are all the decent men not in my
dms that's for sure you get me i feel
like i'm rolling with the man then
what's going on about your fives it
seems like a lot of men don't know how
to treat a lady i'll just manhandle
everything and this girl's putting a
chest and chest in the napkin
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
my name is kels and i'm here for a day
which i seen i've been on a couple of
dates i want to show how it started
properly you know i mean
i don't get nervous and notes this is
just
two people meeting up and just
catching a vibe but not catching my
brothers you know i'm competing if notes
did really well nothing right it's a
good day came with a bottle of bubbly as
well but it's all right so so uh i'm
confident you know what i mean
what to expect from a kind of first day
no assumptions i hate some girls have so
many assumptions man and then look at me
it's always assumptions like i bet you
get better girls like stop
do you get better girls
no i'm cool with it i think it's all
about what you attract right now
if it vibes and actually happens a kiss
at the end will be cool
[Music]
i didn't know what hello
make some roses oh that's really nice oh
thank you
how are you thank you
thank you i'm cheyenne by the way what's
your name kells nice to meet you he got
me flowers
tick
yes
you guys thank you so do you thank you
sorry that's really cute
yeah i thought you like them yeah no i
do i love it thank you like a roses girl
do you like roses
it's not my favorite flower what's your
favorite flower i don't have i just like
pretty like a bunch of pretty pretty
yeah i'll remember that no no thank you
that's all right flowers and i such i'll
do that all my dates just let you guys
know not all the dates that sounds so
bad what am i talking about actually you
know what that's is that good for your
bad thing so tell me about yourself i'll
play rugby american football not
american football did two out to handle
and a couple of other tv shows that's
right okay
you about you i'm from essex and
i create content and i feed homeless
people so if you ever want to come
volunteer with me yeah i'm done we'll do
that yeah let's do it i just feeding
homeless people that's a tick someone
that's giving selflessly i already got
the second day in a bag come on
obviously you can smell about the people
and giving back to
them okay oh thank you probably it's
binding you can't break that oh i see i
like that see oh it's done no the finger
promise so how come you haven't found a
man yet you've been a couple of days now
i realize i'm a bit picky
yeah because i know what i want just not
them cool well from season one to season
two yeah what has that changed has that
altered have you added to that list you
know what it is it's like i i like vibes
and i feel like until i get that vibe i
can't just settle yeah completely you
shouldn't have to exactly what about you
how long you've been single i came out a
relationship last year uh-huh but after
the relationship i've been in i've only
been in relation with one person it
wasn't like
yeah like ten years but we were together
when i was younger and i got a bit older
we got back together again what would
your ex say about you
i feel i feel like
she would say that
being with me was definitely an
experience she learned a lot
um there's a lot that she uncovered
about herself which she's working on
which i'm working on as well do you know
what is
i think she'd have good things to say
about me good things yeah i think she'd
have areas of improvement to say about
me as well which i have worked on which
is normal you said a lot of words but
you didn't actually say anything yeah
i'm just practicing for being a
politician you know what i mean did i
put him on the spot if he's a bit
nervous we'll see
i want to settle
so i feel like relationships in between
just being with someone helps you evolve
and like that time you spend by yourself
helps you understand what you're looking
for and what you're not into do you feel
like you're like in a better state of
mind than you were last year oh
absolutely i feel i'm big on personal
development i think i dropped that bar
every episode but i'm just big on like
just doing the work yourself and just
not having too many expectations you
also have to like level up yourself
after my break i went to bali so i was
better for like three months
later just disconnected focused on
myself yoga meditation everything you
need i was like i remember walking
around the village just talking to
myself start journaling there's so much
you learn by just focusing yourself that
you didn't know before like so many
traumas you like unlock
that you didn't know before i didn't
have that issues but apparently i do but
it's made me want to be more of a
provider because i never had that
growing up oh wow would you say you're
spiritual i understand i love a
spiritual man i think there's different
levels of awakening right because it
depends on where you are on your journey
but i definitely believe in like more
and i definitely believe in being in
sync and i feel
when you spend time with yourself
everything else quiets down and you can
hear like a lot
more i like that
he's attractive
so what are you interested in peace i
love peace i love traveling yeah i like
traveling i like exploring i'm an
adventurer it's in my sad traits meeting
new people having great conversation
sports gym
i like discovering myself i enjoy that
and i like creating content where did
you grow up austria austria yeah yeah
tell me about that so i was born in
australia i speak german that's my first
language
came to uk when i was 14
had a single mom got
two brothers five sisters that was
interesting austral was interesting it
was a bit racist growing up so when i
came here like yeah hey fun fact when
people were looking at me and girls were
looking at me and talking and smiling i
actually think something was wrong with
me because in austria you're not used to
girls like you don't mean so before i
went uni for my confidence to be like
okay yeah other than that it was just
like why are you not looking to smile at
me it's a bit weird oh yeah but growing
up like clothes were from charity shops
and that's what i like the fact you're
like helping other people that used to
be it was crazy yeah what was it like um
growing up with a single mom do you
think that changes the way that you view
women
my mum being a single mom had to take on
masculine energy my mom is a nigerian
mum my mom is a very dominant person a
very strong alpha person so i think when
she told me growing up this is what a
man should be like she'd be like his yes
would be yes and a man should not like
lie be real smell good but it's not just
about looks it's all about that you can
provide and look after family these
things are important for a woman to
trust in you
so growing up with my mom
we used to clash a lot
but then knowing what i know now when a
woman is on her own she takes on some
masculine energy so she changes a little
bit we used to clash but then what i
realized now she was just an adult that
had kids i'm an adult i could have kids
right now i don't but then you just know
that you're figuring stuff out right so
now i know that my relationship with her
is amazing because i think it's
important if you have a good
relationship with your mum and your
sisters no he's talking a lot of sense i
like it not having a dad you don't see
how couples communicate you don't see
how people
deal with conflict you don't have a dad
telling you by the way women are like
this on just sometimes you just gotta
smile and nod and just do what mom says
you don't get all these things so you
find out free trial and error which is
what my relationship was all about yeah
i really really like that
how many women have you slept with
that's a bit techie i might leave that
one i don't think it's relevant
tell me why relevant i'll tell you i
just want to know because for me like i
see that you're a spiritual person like
energy exchange and stuff
it's an interesting question it's like
obviously i'm not a car so like how much
money i've got it's not it's not
relevant but usually when people ask
that question it's because they're
trying to find something out it's an
indicator they're trying to guess or
like have make assumptions or whatever
just tell me what it is you need to know
about me about my personality or how my
life's lived and i'm happy to answer
that so you don't want to actually
answer yeah that's a bit of a mad one
still i'm not i'm not answering that
deplete the fifth
that's relevant it's like i wouldn't ask
you because i don't really care
do you mean i'm more interested in like
who you are and the person you are your
body can't be relevant fine doesn't want
to tell me his body count but no double
standards so it's fine by me
so it's irrelevant if i'd slept with
like a hundred men would it still be
irrelevant
just let me find a man right but would
that not change the way that you view me
as a woman you know what before i always
say yes but one thing i've realized a
lot of people make assumptions and
everyone's assumption is completely
different right i could say that oh you
slept with 100 men okay you're like a
[ __ ] right but it doesn't mean that you
could just have fun or you just be like
you could be someone that trusts easy
and a lot of people just telling you
dreams doesn't make sense there's
different factors that
relate to your body oh you could have
trauma right you could be looking for
love you could have daddy issues you
could have a lot of things it doesn't
mean you're a bad person so i feel like
you know to be the person we are now we
haven't have to go through a stage of
like child error i went through trial
and error just in general i yeah what if
i'd stuck with two of your friends then
that's insane that's that's a group chat
yes i can't right
that's because you know what i'll be
very honest i'm
full body count doesn't matter i'm very
prideful right with guys when you have a
girl it's like asking my girl that's my
princess like you don't know about
everyone wants her but you don't know
about she's going to say you want to
talk to your boys about a girl right
it's not it's not yoga i'm not miss i'll
go we're talking about our girl right
now do you know what i mean it's just
like if i'm your girl now yeah yeah but
even when we're having a group chat and
i'm talking to the players how's our
girl doing do you know me it's just like
i just don't want i think certain things
need to be kept sacred i say if we were
getting on and i had said would you then
just ditch me no we'd be friends yeah
if we've got good energy and good vibes
we have a great convo we've got to be
friends we could go she should what if
we had a good connection it's your pride
there like we'd have to we'd have we'd
have to move to a different era like
different countries really we have to be
different time zones to my friends so
i'm always constantly talking to them
yeah make new friends move to la or
something what's a red flag for you bad
breath bad breath yeah that's the only
red flag he's very specific isn't he do
you know what i'm gonna date at uni
right yeah
and i bought this got ice cream and then
there was ice cream on her fingers and
she wiped on her jeans that put me off
because i was like why don't you just
get tissue do you know what i mean like
we were next to the ice cream stand
let's get a tissue she was like you know
what she said she was like fine it's
just
but that tells me so much about it how
do you do anything so i do everything if
you're wiping ice cream on your jeans
you don't care maybe just
you know everyone was brought up
differently yeah i'm completely
understanding but remember what i just
said how you do anything is how you do
everything so how you do that tells me a
lot about
you without even knowing what i just
know that i don't want to [ __ ] with that
what did it tell you oh when i'm about
to tissue do you say you have to ask me
what your fingers i'll lick my fingers
you click your fingers yeah because if
you're holding it anyway you just would
lick your fingers i'd be like babe just
wait i'll give you a tissue like you
don't have to do that then it's already
in my hand yeah and the ice cream stand
is just there with tissue and there's
loads of stuff on it but to be honest
when that's happening i'm very observant
so as you have an ice cream i've noticed
it before even like i'll be like yo oh
that's cute i got your score that's cute
when was the last time you cried i think
i cried in bali
badly yeah
why i think when i uncovered the whole
daddy trauma thing so let me explain
that because if i don't add context to
that it might sound like completely mad
finally a guy that's emotionally
available
yes
one of the best things i do is cry i
don't cry regularly it's not like i'm
crying all the time but it's a good
release generally guys if you cry i
don't feel no way about it it helps you
process things you feel relieved
top tip
but i feel like because i haven't didn't
have a dad growing up everything i do
now because i'm the oldest in my family
i strive to like get a certain type of
wealth so i can look after them so but
even it's not just about money like i'm
going through life making experiences
learning from my mistakes i didn't have
a dad telling me about myself i'm making
my own mistakes i always wanted a dad
that you can go to like you know the
movie dads you can go to that i can talk
to you about girls because he had girls
gathering talks about sports because
he's been the legend when he comes to
sports got to talk to you about finance
because she's got that all sorted out so
i think i want to become that person i
didn't realize that my urge to become
that person is because i never had that
person do you ever suffer with mental
health
you know i've done a lot of work with
mental health and i feel like
before mental health people used to
think that it just means like you're
like
people in the mental home but it's a lot
more like if you're feeling so depressed
so i'm all about physical health right
mental health is literally the opposite
it's about your mind i think there's a
lot of connotations of it that gives it
like people are scared to admit it
because it means that that they're crazy
or whatever no it's not it's just if
your body's not healthy you have
physical like health issues if your
mind's not healthy you have many other
issues when the show first came out when
i first came into line like i've gone
from like three thousand followers to
like
like 500 000 plus overnight that caused
me anxiety i've never known anxiety if
you look at my background in sports in
school i was naturally very smart very
good at sports
so things come to me quite easy so when
i'm in a situation like
i'm dealing with these feelings i didn't
know anxiety was at the time everyone
goes through mental health i think if
you have a healthy mind it's because
you've worked on it you're investing it
you're doing meditation or you're
reading but everyone goes for it you
know if you're feeling sad today that's
a sign of mental health yeah i do really
like him you know
am i your type are you my type
that's a great question what is your
type i don't have a time that's the
reason i said it's a great question oh
really i like rare individuals i like
someone that's beautiful for their own
rights i don't like someone that looks
exactly the same like anyone else i
don't want to walk down westworld and
just see this girl and then be like go
to boots and see the same looking kind
of person i think once you have a tap
you start judging people and if it
doesn't match that criteria you start
thinking that person's not good enough
you don't actually take the time to get
to know that person that's good i like
that listen no one wants the same girl
i've got i haven't got a type i like
special girls like girls that look
different it's like pokemon you don't
want to keep catching pikachu it makes
no sense you'll catch those rare ones
out there do you know what i mean
there's ones where they have that master
ball ready go like
come on how much money do you earn how
much money do i earn
well do you know what i'm vat registered
so
that kind of tells you that ballpark
figure
of i'm doing all right doing all right
how much is a right
i think all right it's if you can get
yourself a house pay for the mortgage
have a nice car
still travel still feed yourself fee and
then you have the capacity as well left
over to if you now have a kid and a
family you can feed for them
i think that's all right what do you
want our life
loving these questions by the way
getting me to think money look after my
family i want my siblings to go you know
be like oh i've got rent to pay that's
cool i've got that sent you that then
i've got my family i've got someone i
love i've got kids maybe hopefully a
business doesn't take too much away from
but still keeps me mentally stimulated
because i think that's important and i
want to be able to just go sit on a park
bench
yeah i feel like that is the epiphany of
being chilled when you sit in a park
bench
and you just sit there with paper or
whatever i just bread and just sit and
look around and you have no one saying i
need to be here you're not thinking [ __ ]
i can i've only got like three hours to
be here just chill leave when you want
people watch do whatever you want i
think that's chilled it's the simple
things
i get it
by the way i looked at my space photos
oh my god
check the mice face her globe was nuts
now it's like chilling she's a glow up
i'm all about it yeah i was actually
like yeah i saw that yeah abused in
school so i get the ugly duckling
syndrome thing that shows so much about
your character and how you've evolved
people in school people in school that
were the best looking thing about like
right best looking always got girls they
peaked too early and then when you see
them now i'm tess going like yeah what's
going on with you mate when did you last
have sex it's been months
i'm currently practicing semen retention
i feel like sexual sex right now
is an exchange of energy and i think
like i've had
i've had my 20s
i've experienced but it feels empty
enough do you know your own people talk
about that post not
clarity
what
post not
clarity
post not clarity it's when you've had
sex with someone
and then after you've ejaculated you're
like how do i do that man but that
doesn't happen if you're with someone
that you care about and you love
tomorrow i cannot smile i like that
thank you so of you i like the questions
you're giving me as well because you
know it's important when you're on a
date that you're meant to stimulate i
think some people ask the wrong
questions so many people
think that quantity is more important
than quality we can go in 10 days
whenever that real conversation i still
don't know anybody yeah i like a bit
depth i understand it's all about depth
so if you had a one night stand and you
got a girl pregnant yeah
what are you doing sit down like this
yeah explore the options
and we have a conversation about it
because i know guys sometimes think it's
just you get rid of the baby it's not
like that because once that happens
whether it's like one day two days or
like eight weeks your body knows he's
pregnant so your body's already doing
changes whether you like it or not
you're already going for it so you're
already getting attached emotionally
without you even realizing you're
getting attached to something if you
wanted to keep it then you're keeping
i'm not going to tell you it's your body
like i know people think it's a both
decision it's both decisions like the
kid's life is both our decisions but
it's your body whether you want to
remove it or not obviously i preferably
would have to like to have a kid
with someone i want to get married to
and i would tell her to
and if you understand that and you
understand that potentially there may or
may not be a position or a chance in
which we get end up being together
and you're cool with that i'm cool
i really like that answer i can tell she
advances to me it's good vibes if you're
connected she smiling like seeing her
eyes the light the eyes never lie chico
the eyes never lie what turns you on in
the bedroom so submissive i like that
that turns me on what you've been
submissing no
so you're dominant then yeah
okay why are you don't mind it but it's
got to be right yeah 100 do you know
what i don't understand why girls who
look at me and when i have sex with me
i'm like six six massive if i was a girl
i'd be like i don't want that no i think
that's why we like it just something
it's interesting
you know what i mean yeah yeah like
because it's like yeah you just want
something that you can look up at like
you're fine to me yeah you are
attractive you're quite attractive as
well thank you
yeah do you know i never really asked
that what
if someone finds me attractive maybe not
no i think that you can tell you just go
about vibes what
what you already know doesn't need to be
said yeah i mean so if we're like
connecting your smile and tells me
everything about it but
yeah before i find out
no he's a charmer isn't he
i wouldn't just do it to
anyone
i thought you said you don't just sleep
with anyone
wait how's that i know you said you
don't like just
yeah but i'm just saying if there's any
i'm just giving you context if it's in a
relationship yes okay
anyone is eternal phrase okay don't read
into
come
what do you thought yeah
i said yeah
but
when is my husband
married she's not giving headaches she's
a husband that's a lie she's not wearing
a husband fact listen if we're in a
relationship and we're vibing she'll do
it you've never
given it to anyone that's not your
husband okay well i have but i've since
i've been doing this celibacy thing yeah
i'm not doing it unless it's my husband
so i'm just saying yeah because i will
do it well since you're doing celibacy
you're not doing it at all yeah no does
that mean so when i meet my husband
if it's easy to make those choices for
them when you get a relationship with
someone who you'd be like oh that could
be my husband you'll do it yeah okay if
i'm serious about them then i'll do it
i'm just saying
you saying i'm never doing this to my
husband
it's not like i really choose it i know
okay i have done it in the past but i'm
not yeah that's cool and that's fine but
you saying to me now yes i'll do it if i
really care about someone or in relation
to that person that's cool we don't have
to go husband extreme i appreciate your
good girl no one's doubting that i
appreciate you a great woman great
values thank you that's cool
are you waiting for me to go
why are you waiting for me all the time
because you keep doing this like you
keep forgetting what yes or no is yeah
no well you haven't even
yeah yeah it's cool you good at it oh do
i like do i do it no i don't like
but i'm all up from open to depends on
what what's going on there what about
you
yeah i'm selfish i just like a massage
yeah i'm all for that that's all calm
that's good i'm bringing out like a skin
skin brand skin lotion how are you yeah
you like that smells nice you're gonna
do it for me yeah
i want some feedback
yeah cook
so yeah what's your favorite thing to
cook buffalo wings and i made a blue
cheese sauce as well
you love it we're live you're gonna make
it for me yeah yeah
all right cool so weird so we've got the
whole evening planned out yeah feeding
the whole thing timeless body massage
and then yeah buffalo wings perfect sick
perfect night that makes sense
listen the next day is going to be great
we've got feeding the homeless lotion in
her bum
and buffalo wings sheesh that's the
recipe see that see what that's what's
that because
[Music]
yeah see
what's your thoughts on that i will
fight around you i'll fight around you
but i wouldn't want you fighting around
me i know that's double standards i know
i know and i'm probably like getting an
x in the column for this but let me
explain it's just you're like a flower
you're beautiful angels you know i mean
and i know it's
it's such an old-school way of looking
at it i appreciate that i'm aware of
that
i just don't don't you can fart like
walk and fight you know when you walk
and fight and it just disperses all the
time or like or like go to the kitchen
and fall like go back but like if you do
it cool but i'm just like oh that's so
fun
do you know me because i know what my
fight smell like disgusting
in my mind girls don't do number twos
and there's on fire we definitely do
yeah i know you do i try not to think
about that though we do it's just like
it's just
you know i mean girls don't girls don't
do number twos it's just it's just
flowers and rainbows and
chanel five
i can live with that
i'm still gonna fart around him
do you know something really disgusting
what's disgusting
this used to be like my couple goals
it's not anymore i realized i've grown
up but a goal for me used to be like
sitting on the toilet seat and then like
if i'm and you need the toilet at the
same time and we only have one bathroom
you can just like weave through my legs
how does that logistically work so what
like you're like you're like this
exactly and you just piss through as
long as you've got good aim
she was going so well man it was good i
don't like
you know it's always the ones you don't
expect it's funny fact i've been on
dates with pissing people's things
do you know why it's just let me explain
it's not like i just go around pissing
people sick why did i say that
girls would you stay friends with an axe
yes depends on what how we broke up if
it's like i broke up with uh then i
could stay friends with her if it's over
run uh really it's just the attachment
on it if she's broken up with you and
you still want to be with her you can't
be friends with that because then
it kills guys mentally kills us the
thought of you having sex with someone
else mentally destroys us especially for
another finger it's even worse it's like
waking up inception every time you're
looking for that spinny thing but you
can't find it i actually go for dinner
with my ex yeah you guys friends yeah
that's cool i just can't do it but if
you can do it
obviously if you say to me i'm friends
with my ex they'll be like you still
have romantic no yeah this is the child
of you
no yes whatever it's cool i don't think
you'd be cool with that yes whatever i'm
i'm i'm really not insecure person like
100 said that yeah
yeah sorry i'd like that
i'll pick you up after
see pull up to that nose like you'll be
saying
that's cool have you ever ghosted
someone yeah
yeah yeah
how comes
i just wasn't feeling it anymore
i was doing so well it's definitely
ghosted affair for you women
but like we got not ghosts tonight we're
not talking like
we've been going on bad dates and just
ghosted sometimes you just
you get a message from someone or like
because you're busy or you don't reply
stuff and you get paragraphs i'm just
like yeah i don't really have time for
this i don't want to do that but did you
not just at least say like a really nice
woman just not for me
nothing yeah but that's not the rule
it's just happened a couple of times you
asked me a question a few times
how many people have been ghosted
well
again i'm not the person i am before and
i'm a lot older now but when i was like
young in my teens and my 20s
it was just you know i mean remember you
talking now about ghosting right and the
implications and the effect it has on
the female i wasn't thinking like that
back then
and neither were you do i mean you were
probably going through the feelings if
you weren't yeah cause i was probably
the woman getting ghosted and then in my
feelings now just i say like a little
hey just not feeling this anymore um
but we're cool so you'd say that
yeah and then essay boom then what then
what just because you said menace it
doesn't have to reply to that but do not
feel guilty
i don't have expectations of you you
should have expectations of me if i send
you an essay no reply me being obsessed
about that
that's my expectations are set on you
you've not agreed to this exception
expectations what's the difference
between a woman that you would like wife
and one you'd have one night with
if she got pregnant right now would you
keep it
that's the answer that's the hard part
so i asked myself yeah but like how how
do you determine so like say for example
like for example me yeah
at what point would you determine oh
she's just one girl i take home for one
night or she's one that actually i
wouldn't mind like having a future with
how we have conversations so at first
the looks i feel like looks get you
through the door and personality makes
you stay
he writes himself doesn't he
do you write him
yes
i write him
so if you're on paper like looks like
something i'm really interested in
someone i want to get married to
then as i get to know you and how you
make conversation how you make banner
how you take it on information will tell
me if this is someone
okay
what would you do if my ex was after you
well he's after me because
what reason because i'm with you you've
got some issues going on you know
probably sit down have a chat but like
like bro she's gone let it go
yeah yes like what are you doing man
yeah that's a good way to deal with that
of course like i would have come and say
i'll sit down with him like listen you
understand that i don't i didn't know
you existed right and when i spoke to
you you were in a relationship with her
so thinking about the same way you're
talking to another girl i'm talking to
her and then we got close and now here
we are
bro stop it yeah it's very nice and
diplomatic yeah
kick what would you do if i wanted to
start an only fans what are you doing on
there
let's say adult industry content oh
explicit stuff yeah
yeah do it i won't i'll tell you that i
won't wife you like
what
i mean we can see each other what you do
is you but i just don't want people
seeing everything you have again it goes
back to the remember if i'm if i have
issues between my friends sleeping with
you
tonight what everyone sees explicit
content of you i guess you know what
maybe maybe it's worth having a
conversation
if you're sending pictures of like you
in bikini like yeah why would you just
like underwear
yeah it's cool i just
it just gives you a bad reputation of so
many ways to make money
you're still stepping into the industry
yeah it's just grades to it yeah do you
watch porn no
i had my first wank when i was like 22.
really yeah i just didn't see the idea i
didn't i didn't i feel like if you can
have sex why do you have to want
that's good because i feel like porn
gives unrealistic expectations on sex oh
yeah messed me up oh really yeah yeah
but it made me good
my dream because i thought i was a sick
porn star
what would you do if i didn't want to
sleep with you for the first six months
of our relationship
honestly we'd have a conversation about
it you see how we just compromised early
on yeah we see if we can find a
compromise okay
yeah do you want to try to reduce our
symptoms good behavior
what if i wanted to involve other people
in our sex life okay
you're down yeah yeah yeah it was
swinging closer
yeah
wait who picks a goal you do i do
obviously
like if a woman if you're gonna do it i
feel like the rule should be
the woman would have to pick but i don't
want her anyway i feel yeah do you know
what i'm thinking about i don't know if
it's like maybe it's the idea of having
the idea that you like but in reality
it's just like
yeah
yeah cool oh say no
i feel like women
i'm not going to be like let's have a
free song now for that bring it up
that's a different story remember you're
asking me a question yeah
you want it i don't want it i'm not
going to say no to your dreams but just
say no
no because i feel like i'd rate you
better because i feel like in my head
now i'm like what you want to sleep with
other women yeah but
but you just yeah you just said that you
said you said that yeah wait but you
just said you did yourself
but you know you just said
you're saying that because in your head
you're like do you want to sleep over
women no recognize that that's your
thought that's your internal thought
you've asked me a question i said yes
because i want to make you happy so this
might not make me happy just ask me the
question yeah because you're supposed to
say no you found the test
i don't want to but if it makes you
happy i'll do it
oh how noble
i could never
what would you do if your friends are
liking my selfies
as i said i'm not an insecure person
because of people i don't know liking
photos
okay what if i couldn't cook you would
learn to cook it's not a problem
like that you're very chill oh yeah it's
just like if you don't not everyone
knows everything
do you i mean
what if i was in the gang
it's allen road like top way i thought
it just sounds weird coming out my mouth
but yeah we'll have to end that we'll
talk we'll start gradually getting you
out and start talking about how we can
get you out because i know it's nice
easier just to walk away in it sometimes
what would you if i was in a gang no i'm
not about that life what if i'm like
power i'm ghost like i'm like this
normal living normal life i've got
people doing i've got a tommy that's
doing all the things just running me
that money no because i've got a club
i'm legit no i've just got tommy running
me money it's not legit you say that now
no when you see the other side of life
and the effects that these lifestyles
have on people that have regular lives
and families ruined
it's no from me what if i say i've ever
free a plan to become legit yeah they're
more episodes three years they don't get
caught in it i get legit i'm legit
no still until you actually legit clean
but you still be with me until i'm
literally no i won't hit me up in three
years when you're legit then in it
interesting okay i'm known again
um how do you think you've done i think
i've done all right i think we've done
the right it's like collaborative i've
ever revived we've had that yeah we've
had banner
we've had some deep conversations
stimulating conversation
exchanged a couple smiles made a couple
of pinky promises i know if you like the
next day you'll plan out
yeah it's been good how do you think you
did
yeah i'm good yeah yeah i think i've
done good it is well
which is
it was a really good day
yeah the day was good i really enjoyed
that you know i thought she was gonna be
no i didn't actually i came in with good
mindset that we can talk communicate
grilling is only green if you've got
things to hide i couldn't even grill him
because he was just like really charming
so yeah it was hard i could tell she was
into me
and
i wish she's a cool girl i like it it's
cool yeah i'd like to see cows again 100
we've got already got a date line up you
know what there wasn't actually any red
flags i feel like she's going to give me
a bob like at 8.5
i'm going to give curls
a
[Music]
9.2 because i think we had the best vibe
so far out of everyone updated
and you got the roses
you